أعلم أنني أقوم بتدريبه ، حسنًا ، لم أفكر أبدًا في
أنني سأحصل على وظيفة في مجال الطعام ،
فهذه مطحنة الذرة الخاصة
بنا ونطحن الذرة هنا كل يوم
سأقول دائمًا ، عندما أتقاعد سأذهب
إلى فيلا في توسكانا  ونقوم بإفطار أفضل ،
لا ينبغي لأحد أن يفعل ذلك عندما
يتقاعدون ، نحن في حفل في سان فرانسيسكو ،
إنه
مطعم افتتحته قبل ثلاث سنوات وهو
مطعم مكسيكي للمأكولات البحرية كنت حقًا
في فكرة صنع نوع مكسيكي
من الطعام يفعله الناس  هنا لم أكن أعرف شيئًا
عن ذلك ، فقد فتحت هذا
المطعم المشهور جدًا في مكسيكو سيتي قبل 20 عامًا ،
وقد طُلب منا عدة مرات القيام بنسخ
من ذلك ، قررنا أن
سان فرانسيسكو كانت مناسبة بشكل أفضل ،
لطالما كانت سان فرانسيسكو مدينة مقبولة حقًا لـ
طاهيات سيدات هناك تقليد طويل حقًا
للسيدات اللواتي حصلن على
وظائف مذهلة وكان لهن تأثير كبير ، كنت
أعمل مع شريك إيما الأول وقالت إيما ،
هل ستكون على استعداد لتوظيف أشخاص
لديهم تاريخ اقتناع تعرف
أنه يوجد كل هؤلاء أو  العمارات
في المدينة التي تساعد الناس في العثور على وظائف
بعد انتهاء وقتهم في الخدمة
وتوصلنا إلى هذا النظام لتوظيف
جزء كبير من موظفينا من خلال هذه
المنظمات ، أحد الأشياء
الأكثر إثارة في هذه الصناعة هو
أن ما أنت عليه  القيام به هو رعاية
الأشخاص الذين يجب أن تعانقهم دائمًا
وتتحرك وتأكد من احتضانهم
عندما تصب وسننظم
فصلًا صغيرًا آخر عن النبيذ لمدة ساعة تقريبًا
نحن هنا من أجلك ، ما هو الأمر المضحك
الذي تهتم به  كل شخص
يعتني بالموظفين الذين
تعتني بضيوفك سان فرانسيسكو
مجتمع تقدمي وسخي للغاية
وحقيقة أن الناس يمكن أن يأتوا إلى
مطعم حيث يعلمون أن
التغيير الاجتماعي يحدث يجعله جذابًا للغاية